washington got to the playoffs last year
they won the division they have
five straight division games to end
the season week two they play the giants
and then no more games against teams
from the nfc east until
week 14 and there it is cowboys eagles
cowboys eagles
giants what what a strange way to end
your season
but you know uh miles it very well could
be that the schedule makers look at and
say hey we don't know what's going to
happen in the nfc east
and it may be none of the above again
and uh maybe it makes for an interesting
stretch run if the team that won the
division last year
is running the easier gauntlet of its
division
to end the season well no i mean they
basically
are in the playoff hunt throughout the
season
right i mean if they get to that stretch
and they're
around 500 then they should in theory be
able to
catch somebody in the division if all
you do is play divisional games
through you know the last five games of
season i i mean
i don't know how much i love it if i'm
washington that i don't play
any familiar opponents for so long in
the season
but at the same time like that's really
i don't say controlling your destiny but
you know whatever it is you know you get
to
really have a real good sense of control
over whether or not you make the
postseason
when you have that many division
contests i feel like in the back half
of the year leave that pull that back up
if you can because
the nfc east was bad last year this year
every team in the nfc east plays every
team in the afc
west and every team in the nfc south
that does not bode well for one of these
four teams
going 12-4 and washington
which i continue to believe is the best
team in the division
because they won it last year they get
the packers
they get the seahawks the other teams in
the division don't get the packers of
the seahawks now
you know they're going to have to play
other teams in the nfc west which which
are pretty good but they don't get the
best teams
the first place team plays those best
teams in the other two divisions where
they don't play
every team it's it could be another
seven and nine maybe even a six and ten
champion in the
a in the nfc east this year miles
because
just the schedule doesn't doesn't fit
well
for those four teams they're gonna have
some tough games well the schedule also
doesn't fit what you just said
i believe it would be eight in you know
nine
oh that's right seven and ten or six
and eleven come on mike you know we
gotta we gotta
get used to it well you better you know
we gotta be flexible we gotta be docile
you know we gotta
react to all the different things that
are happening here man it's the new age
they got a number linebackers are going
to be wearing number 11.
you know it's just the way things are
now
one thing i've been trying to remind
myself of when i talk about this new
season it is the first time there's ever
been 17 games it's not the first time
there's ever been 18 weeks
there was an 18-week season back when
you were in diapers
1993. i assume you were still in diapers
what were you for then
um two when was your birthday and what
what when did you turn two in october
when i turned two in october one day
there's another hit for you it's
my birthday oh it's september
so uh anyway uh there was an 18-week
season then because there were two buys
and
uh so this is the second time there's an
18 week season but 17 games
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports